good I might good  I might good I might I wanna take my  mouth off and throw it at the wall good  I might rise up lights rise of lights  um I'm not gettin it rise up lights rise  up lights rise lights rise up lights  rise up lights rise applies libel libel  fine libel fine libel fine my bull fine  Mabel Thames mobile phone that's only a  second Michael fine call me Mom libel  fine my cocaine my cocaine my cocaine my  cocaine my okay and Mike Michael came  Mike okay Oh Mike okay Mike okay okay  the two words I always put together ah  crash aah crash cough gross ouch my car  crash car crash crash my mother had a  [ __ ] rash whale oil hooked  whale oil beef cooked well well be [ __ ]  whale oil beef hooked I feel like this  is dirty just feels dirty in my mouth  well I'll be hot oh yes well I'll be  [ __ ] that's what it is whale oil beef  cooked whale oil B [ __ ] do I feel like  good wood did I look sexier though when  I was speaking  Australian accent that's very that's the  big thing